on peut y aller mais on peut pas rentrer
on peut pas rentrer en france
c'est pour rester là-bas bloqué à
l'appel pendant que nous on était
interdit de rentrer en italie les
italiens ils pouvaient entrer en france
en toute impunité sans contrôle sans
rien alors que nous on nous a toujours
interdit de rentrer en italie
maintenant que les frontières sont
ouvertes qu'on nous a informé hier que
ça serait ouvert aujourd'hui il ya des
problèmes et ben oui apparemment il ya
des gens qui font demi tour mais comme
on ne sait pas pourquoi j'ai failli
faire demi-tour moi-même et tenter
éventuellement par la frontière du duo
mais si on nous irons nous refoulons ne
refoule vous pouvez passer du côté
italien pour revenir
il vous faudra une attestation
international de circulation il vous
faudra de surcroît une attestation de
domicile votre carte d'identité et un
motif valable et non food in d'être allé
en italie sans quoi vous risquez 135
euros d'amendé